they came from all over the country NHS
workers who say they're facing the
biggest crisis of their working lives
with record a e and ambulance waiting
times putting people's lives at risk
they say an unbearable thought for those
who spent a Lifetime on the front line
I'm a retired pediatrician I've never
seen such fear and demoralization in NHS
staff in my life
running food banks for their staff who
can't afford the cost of living so we
will carry on losing stuff and not be
able to recruit new staff unless the
government wake up and say and treat the
public servants that they are with
respect and pay them a decent living
wage
but no such offer is on the table
according to unions and all the while
these nurses say it's the patients who
suffer patients aren't getting the right
things done for them because there's not
enough staff there to provide it that's
that's the bottom line every single day
patients are suffering nurses are
suffering they're suffering from burnout
they're suffering from low morale
because our government have completely
abandoned us they stood out on the
streets and they clap for us and now
they've turned their backs
you know it's devastating it's it's
heartbreaking to me her emotion echoed
by many here people here are angry they
say they're overworked and undervalued
and they had to take to the streets to
fight for the future of the NHS a future
which they say must start with increased
pay
without it the Health Service will
continue to hammer its staff this junior
doctor says I open up Instagram and I'm
and I see ads to go work in Australia to
go work in New Zealand this government
they will recruit uh you know from
abroad
um and and there are huge ethical
concerns in that but why aren't they
talking about staff retention
in response the government said we have
prioritized Health and Social care
services with up to 14.1 billion pounds
over the next two years on top of record
funding we're also making progress to
recruit more staff with more than 4 900
doctors and almost 11 100 more nurses
compared to a year ago
the support for workers today came from
a familiar face actor Rob Delaney whose
young son was treated by the NHS before
his death from cancer lived here nine
years so that means most of my life was
spent getting Health Care in the United
States
you know with a really horrible barrier
of Private health insurance and between
me and my family's care
in the UK you don't have that and it's
spectacular so I'll fight for the NHS
until I'm in the ground
a fight that workers here say they're
ready to continue Milena vaselinovic Sky
News